la fase de rescate está llegando a su
fin
estas fueron las palabras de Martin
griffith GP ayuda de la ONU en su visita
a Siria ahora el foco estará en brindar
asistencia humanitaria a los
sobrevivientes
luego de las operaciones de búsqueda y
rescate sigue otra fase humanitaria dar
urgentemente albergue a los
sobrevivientes atención psicosocial
alimentación escolarización y sentido de
futuro esa es nuestra obligación ahora
pero antes del anuncio de la ONU en
áreas del noroeste de Siria controladas
por grupos Rebeldes y fundamentalistas
el silencio en medio de las montañas de
escombros ya reinaba en ciudades como
alepo
A diferencia de su vecina Turquía la
defensa civil y los organismos de
rescate no cuentan con los equipos
necesarios para encontrar sobrevivientes
una consecuencia del desgaste de casi 12
años de guerra
en la taquia la ayuda de la sociedad
civil reemplaza la estatal
cerca de 25 familias del barrio se
refugiaron aquí y están aquí desde el
día del terremoto gracias a dios hay
gente que hace el bien y trajeron comida
debería entrar por territorio Bajo su
control durante años la ayuda
humanitaria llega a la zona Rebeldes a
través de Turquía en un proceso que
requiere la aprobación cada seis meses
del Consejo de Seguridad de la ONU
acaba de entrar un convoy de ayuda de la
ONU con 10 camiones cargados con
diversos suministros de Socorro y
materiales necesarios para tiendas de
campaña e higiene
según la ONU el 90% de la población del
noroeste sirio estimado en unas 4
millones de personas depende de la ayuda
humanitaria